I'm Sandy Irani I am the associate
director of the Simons Institute and I'm
fortunate today to have with me Ali Ray
Smith and we're going to hear about his
amazing extraordinary career working in
academic research and teaching computer
graphics and animation filmmaking
executive leadership writing and art so
um welcome Albie it's really a pleasure
to have you here it's fun to meet you
right you know when you live I'm in my
80th year so when you live that long the
stories just rack up just ensure it just
time we're looking forward to that so
we're going to touch on a lot of the
work but um to start with can you tell
me a little bit about your early life my
early life was in New Mexico okay I was
born in Texas I'll bet I would tell
people that I grew up in New Mexico okay
and I had an artist uncle
taught me how oil paint ah this is very
important it turns out in the long run I
didn't know
he would let me into his Studio
as long as I wouldn't say anything
absolutely quiet and sit on the floor
okay it was painful and quiet but I just
did it yeah I did it you know I watched
I learned how to prepare canvas and
clean the brushes and make some oil
paintings and get fall in love with that
smells the smells of it and oil painters
studio and then I became an oil painter
myself for a lot of years an important
influence on many aspects of your career
right and and I also went to school at
New Mexico State University which is
right next to White Sands and Missile
Range where Rockets were taking off all
the time so high tech Wisconsin
got to introduce
to buy somebody from White Sands to this
marvelous
and fell in love like so much
and you know years later I put those two
things together magically so you had the
Confluence of Art and Tech right there
right there from the beginning yeah
now you begin your research uh early
research and theoretical computer
science studying cellular automata
theory is that right that's right can
you tell me a little bit about that
period of your life what questions were
you thinking about at the time what
motivated you to move on from there well
let me back up just a little bit I came
from New Mexico to Stanford a graduate
school
because I want to learn this new subject
called artificial intelligence
this is 1965. okay now and I've learned
this from McCarthy and after a couple
years I said I don't think this is going
to happen
all right
and you know I'm revisiting that now but
uh
nobody could show me the way and I
couldn't sit into a logical path from
what I was being taught to how this
works that's what I really wanted to
know right
but I still want to yeah and um so I
I changed to computation Theory
and I was particularly attracted to
Cellular automata Theory because
um in what we call themselves and I was
interested in living things which were
made of cells and I thought or at least
poetically there was some connection
between living things and Cellular
automata in fact I wrote my thesis on
salt reproducing machines okay
which again I thought of as well not
really life but it's life like yeah it
might be a pathway to understanding
the computation we think of as a living
thing
right I think that's still a possibility
but I left it behind so I see the
connection because Ai and cellular
automata I'm sorry connecting the the
math and the Cs no there was even a
artificial life they called it okay yes
and I went to the Santa Fe Institute one
year and percent of my
self-read reducing machine concept it
was a selfie non-trivial
self-reproducing
machines had to be to be computation
Universal okay or didn't count yeah okay
okay so Von Neumann had done it first he
had um
had uh
written almost finished a book
proving the existence of a
self-reproducing machine
and it was you know the book
it was the Von Norman died and it was
finished by somebody else but
um I took that and I reduced that book
to eight pages was mine I use the
recursion through Romans yeah it just
turns it pulse out from the recursion
zero yeah which is I guess
I didn't know simplification is a
beautiful thing
oh okay that's easy too easy you know
all right okay mathematically I did a
one-dimensional universal cellular
automatic oh it's great but then art
comes back into it because
um
Remember The Game of Life the Game of
Life came out and in Scientific American
Magazine and I remember I was in New
York City by now teaching
NYU
and
I looked at in Martin Gardner's column
which I've grown up reading
was about the game of life and I said I
knew immediately that was a so that are
a ton of time and I could tell by
reading that nobody had Associated those
two things
on so I decided to call my hero Martin
Gardner who lived up the Hudson River
somewhere
and tell it and I did that and he said
well that's remarkable can I come down
and spend the day with you
great yeah
yeah and he did and he came down and so
this is the time this is the
I graduated in 69 still had the long
hair you know I still have the hippie
look and it's so did most young males in
New York City at the time so Martin
Garners nice little man comes down and
he he looks around and he's got a
shocked
that her suit all the males were and I
was in kind of shock that he was shocked
because
his book the
um
Illustrated Alice that's not the right
one it was Alice in Wonderland oh
the annotated out the annotated Alice in
Wonderland
was reading in the acid underworld of
the of the United States he didn't
didn't understand he didn't know why it
was so popular oh my gosh I can't even
tell this guy that's just too big a
culture
[Laughter]
and he says something like you know I'm
just a philosopher
and played it simply said I'm just a
philosopher I don't know math very well
can you explain the details so I had
proved the theorem at an early switching
an automatic theory conference
yes
on
recognizing a palindrome in real time
with a cellular automata okay Tom
proved that theorem I just proved it so
when
when Martin Gardner came to me and said
you know that subject has been the most
popular subject Scientific American has
ever published well The Game of Life yes
and the publisher wants to make it the
cover story of the next issue which
would be
for 71.
and he so you should you should submit
some cover designs and I'll submit some
cover designs and the publisher will
select one to be the cover all right so
the first thing that came to my mind was
a colorized proof of this space-time
diagram that I've used to prove that
palindrance could recognize the cellular
topic of that nice valid drugs in real
time real simple proof yeah
I think that's all I submitted was that
one design
he submitted a couple of designs by
oolong which by all right shows one
but the publisher assigned to American
was a palindrome but
oh okay
and
all of a sudden I started getting
letters of all over the world
and I suddenly felt oh this must be what
Fame feels like okay your little just a
little bit of something
nice yeah I'm not sure why but this case
it was a game of life and deciding that
that coming together and
um which in the world of science this is
this is big news
yeah I'm this little kid from New Mexico
right and okay uh this is actually those
Fox papers don't have such beautiful
artwork to go with them too so it's
really easy well it was pretty simple
yeah art art is kind of a loose term for
this but it was colorful yeah and uh I'm
still proud of it
um
yeah that so it turns out again I think
my major my major contributions to
theoretical computer science are
pictures not theorems although I did
some theorems too well it's good we're
happy to have all the contributions so
um now you were the first director of
computer Graphics at lucasfilm yes
um how did you make the jump to Industry
from Academia what was the impetus to do
that
basically uh
so
I I could
let me back up a little bit I broke my
leg skiing when I was a professor in New
York New Hampshire I think I broke this
femur and I was laid up for three months
and during that three months I said you
know I'll be you're not doing anything
about your part you're making
it was proving clearance is not who you
want so I vowed that when I came out of
the full body cast that I was in
my professorship at NYU
Hawaii but California where something
good would all right now what films did
you work on there
as Lucas Lucasville uh hardly any that
was one of the surprises and the film
the film we worked on was
uh not George Lucas's oh okay it was
Star Trek not Star Wars okay so
Paramount
[Music]
um
a higher industrial line magic which is
the special effects
of lucasfilm to do special effects for
their movie star start Trek 2 the Wrath
of Kong okay and they they wanted to
sell this newfangled computer Graphics
in there in their movie and the guys at
ilm says you know we don't do that but I
think that's what the new guys next door
make to us I think that's what they do
go talk to Alvin that's right yeah they
pull me over and uh
I landed the job for a one minute yeah
shot in Star Trek through the wrath of
Conor
um
so I brought the group together and I
knew this was The Big Break yeah this
was it I had a simple this amazing team
of geniuses I call
them all were I mean just they are
they're just really smart people who
want to be in the movies and
artistically and technically
and uh
George never came and asked for us
okay so when I got this Paramount thing
I realized okay this is the break not
George this is this group
brought the team together I said we got
this we've got the big break
I mean we're going to make people at
Paramount very happy with our shot
and we're going to make people in the
audience that Star Trek is really happy
because they're being there it'll make
lots of narrative sense
to push the movie along story wise but
what this really is
is a 60-second commercial to George
Lucas so he'll know what the hell
okay and he got the message yeah and I
still don't know how I knew this but I
knew George Lucas never never takes his
eye off the camera okay no matter what
the emotion
yeah if you watch it try to watch a
movie
and keep track of the camera the
directors failed
because you haven't been sucked into the
emotion right
it's really hard to I've tried to do it
yeah George could do it yeah I think we
could do both he could track well yeah
right yeah so I said we're going to put
a camera shot in here
that would be impossible for a real
chamber to make it's got spin around and
do all sorts of amazing things it won't
be gratuitous computer Graphics 101 my
way Sally it'll make perfect narrative
sense but it'll show the possibility
he's watching the camera right
so we did that and sure enough the day
after the premiere he stepped foot into
nine one foot he's a kind of a shy guy
stepped one foot in my office he said
great camera shot
you got through yeah and he had us in
his next movie just one which was a
return to the Jedi we had one
simple shot
he told his best buddy Steven Spielberg
about us and remembering his things
my Sherlock Holmes
and then it went far from there so okay
so let's talk about Pixar now so I
looked up your day
and they coincident 86 to 91 which was
exactly my time as a graduate student
here at Berkeley
um and I have a very vivid memory I've
gone with my buddies down to a cinema on
Shattuck
seeing a series of short animators and
seeing that iconic lamp yeah yeah play
with the ball and we were blown away you
know absolutely amazed with it so so
were the animators of the world um I the
best hire of my life was John Laster he
was his animator
foolishly I thought I was an animator
until I met a real one okay and found
out
oh no you're not yeah
and his
he was trained at Cal Arts which was the
school that Walt Disney had formed to
train animators
yeah and he was one of the top graduates
from Cal arts and information character
animation
um
he so he had all these friends from that
world who were skeptical about computers
and animation surely computers are these
rigid right you know yeah so he's
looking around and he John was you know
he was he had left out in front of all
of them that's
guess why I snapped him up and so
obviously was ready
and he was talented
but he needed to prove to his animation
colleagues that computers could do it
so he just looked around at his desk and
look at this film we all had antique
desks this is Marsha Lucas influence and
we had
Green Glass lamps and we had a Luxo lamp
every desk had a nap
so he said well I'll just make that lamp
come on wow
they did
[Music]
and then everybody said and then
everybody said oh
so um John's story is that he was just
shaking his boobs because Jim Glenn is
one of the Geniuses of computer Graphics
approached him he's got a Stern looking
guy he's not really sternum okay
and he said oh no I've done something
wrong I violated something yeah computer
Graphics ethic or something you know
yeah and and all Jim want to know is
what's the gender of the lamps was it a
mother or a father and John
you hit one because it didn't matter you
know what your self-agender was it
doesn't matter it was so imaginative it
was so amazing so
um so tell tell us a little bit about
how you started Pixar and the story of
the name which I believe you came up
with the vice president yeah yeah so we
start this is where the force playing
came in uh George we probably would have
stayed happily at lucasfilm forever if
he hadn't if George hadn't divorced
Marsha okay vice versa whatever they
divorced okay and you know in
California's community property so
overnight George Lucas
fortunate all right so it never was
quite sure who we were right okay we
kind of come in the side door on the
movies
and uh so I went into my partner at one
of the co-founder of Pixar
went into Pat's office and I said yeah
you know uh we're gonna get fired
George never understood Who We Are
and he's just lost half his fortune he
can't support where our group was he saw
it coming foreign
this is not going to work yeah yeah uh
let's start a company
I say
now this is two computer nerds talking
about each other
entrepreneurs we went across the street
this is in Marin County went across the
street to a clean wheel lighted Place
through books okay yeah yeah and bought
four how to start them four business
books yeah
you know
yeah a little thin silly I mentioned
they were Silly books but he got to and
I got two and the amazing thing is it
works you know yeah it was really hard
we we we
quickly figured out that we could not
make a movie yet which is our goal we
had a goal since the set mid 70s you
know being the first group in the world
feature length completely computed
living yeah that was a little ways off
but yeah it took us 20 years but we
didn't know that yeah thank goodness
yeah
uh we we had um because of the event I
won't go into right now we knew was
cold fact that we needed another five
years of Moore's law in order to get
enough computation power
to do a future movie cost effectively
okay okay we're gonna do for five years
yeah we have to we have to start this
company to keep our group of geniuses
together yeah what are they going to do
well software doesn't make enough money
to support that many people
and making television commercials
doesn't make enough money to support
that man
anything we can do Hardware
we have built a machine called the Pixar
image computer for George Lucas
that's kind of paying our data this is
building hardware and software for
George which set satisfied him
let's just turn let's do what they do in
Silicon Valley we'll take our prototype
capitalize it and turn it into a product
and sell it even though we don't know
anything about it yeah
then we went through the heart problem
of we gotta Finance
for business first you have to convince
all 40 people that they're going to sign
on with us and we did that by letting
everybody have a share of the country
all right everybody everybody no matter
what your titleists
um
we got turned down by 35 Venture Capital
firms 35. that's 35 presentations heavy
duty yeah money guys
and they say no
and we said oh okay uh
let's do a strategic partnership with a
large corporation
so we
talked to 10 large corporations and we
almost closed the deal with General
Motors wow and Phyllis yeah
together they were gonna Finance us we
would do car synthesis so they didn't
have to build clay models anymore okay
for General Motors
and we would make it we had a
technology for visualization of
and CT scans and the way I've seen
before is really cool
yeah that was Finance the company and he
was alive
okay weren't sure what would happen in
five years but Just Keep Us Alive okay
that we were in Manhattan closing this
deal I mean breath of the last stage
20 people around a board room on the
40-something floor across the street
from we're in Central Station and you
know all this it's half attorneys and
four parties and I was the most
stressful meeting I've ever
been at the end of the day or by saying
yes it's shaking hands in the business
world that's a tough deal okay well
that's missing is the signatures and the
attorneys have to put into writing what
you just did and you know what happened
the next day and you sign it yeah
formalities at this point right
not in this case because
the part of General Motors we were
dealing with do you remember H Ross
Perot oh yeah yeah
it was his division of General Motors
his company had been bought a German
Motors okay and it was his division
that we were dealing with
the day we were I think it was like two
days separating these two events we were
closing our deal we thought downtown he
was uptown at the General Motors
building
insulting the board of directors of
General Motors
and when that story broke
the night of our supposed deal yeah in
the Wall Street Journal
everybody knew that anything General
Motors the Patriots Pearl was dead and
our deal was right there oh my gosh so
again our friend of you we've got all
that you know persistence and 45 45
attempts yeah and we couldn't think of
anything else and we were frantic and
Lucasville Lucasville has a sign off on
all this because they get a piece
their friend so I remember we're in the
limo leaving Manhattan going back out to
JFK to fly home
and we came up with a Hail Mary idea
that is call Steve Jobs
all right now
we had met him already had been kicked
out of apple
and he had invited the enemy down to his
Mansion at Woodside I remember sitting
out on the grass one day as he proposed
to us that as his next thought he would
buy us from George Lucas and run us as
his next company
and we went nah we want to run our own
family but we'll take our money okay
yeah he says okay
but when he ran his number by Lucasville
it was about half of what General Motors
was talking about okay so they kind of
left him out of the office yeah
so here was our here was our Hail Mary
thought was call him up again and say
make exactly the same offer at half the
valuation of Euro Motors everybody we
did that and I didn't care about the
money we just wanted to stay a lot right
yeah
he did and that's how he became our
venture capitalist amazing if you did
not buy us from Lucasville which is his
version okay all right good to set the
record straight
yes yeah enough about it yeah now you've
played a really Cinema role in
developing digital digital Graphics
um as a technical and artistic medium in
a number of ways can you tell us more
about your sort of influence over the
well the first thing's sort of obvious
that first thing I would do is a paint
program
and that is so
yeah interestingly my first job out of
with my fresh PhD from Stanford was as a
professor at NYU working for a man named
Herbert Friedman who turns out to be one
of the earliest people ever in computer
graphics
and I look back at it and he kept saying
to me why don't you leave this Theory
stuff behind and start contributing to
computer Graphics because he knew nuts
and hearts and he thought it was a
natural fit perfect and I said this to
him I said herb if you ever get color
I'm there okay because it's still right
yeah okay well
broke my leg I come out to California or
something that's going to happen that
something good is Xerox Park okay Xerox
Palo Alto research center right at the
height of it's yeah
so many good ideas came out of it oh it
was such a warm it was such a marvelous
place and my best friend dick shell had
built a painting program
that's his Rock's part with colored
pixels which nobody had seen before
and I saw that and he knew I was an
artist he says Ellie you've got to come
see what I've been doing yeah that's why
I saw each other yeah as soon as I saw
it this was your wishlist this is him
yeah
and I got myself
hired on a park okay
um
they fired me later but because they
decided not to do color this is another
one of those Geniuses right
but you know I got that's how I got to
start and and then I went to
the next place turned out to be a very
wealthy man on the North Shore of Long
Island I mean Alex sure he had a place
called New York Institute Institute of
Technology okay NYIT
he owned this school okay and it was
basically
say that that's stupid
uh yep it was for students who lived on
Long Island with their parents and okay
yeah okay
and uh
he was he also had the same owner
okay
picture this because this is a beautiful
place
It's Great Gatsby land yes it states as
far as you can see in every direction
and this guy Alexander sure I cobbled
together four of these marvelous Estates
on the North Shore
and the buildings on his campus were the
Mansions of these Estates wow wow so we
did video and one Mansion we did
computer graphics on another Mansion
yeah oh it was just great Saturday yeah
yeah this is real yes it was
and uh so my joke is that
we got started in the garage too it just
happened to be a four car garage
a little bit Fancy with the humble
beginnings of many other companies but
he had a he saw himself as the next Walt
Disney and he had a an old he had a 100
person
old-fashioned cell animation team making
a movie called Tubby the tuba and his
idea was you get these computers and
computer Graphics guys us to make it
cheaper to make this movie he'd get
richer I mean he was really an
entrepreneur yeah okay well that didn't
happen quite that way but we learned
from these Old-Timers yeah the business
of an animated movie all the logistics
problems and how you do it and
everything about it
and uh well that's what we said Gee
let's be the first people to do this on
the computer because this is nuts yeah
and we can do a better job too higher
quality job
so if and eventually we did all that
um
but we
we've detected that he wasn't going to
be our future even though we had this
idea of making the first movie with him
yeah we could see he didn't have it all
right tell me the two of it was a heart
yeah
you needed the vision you're right
that's when we got the call from first
Lucas to come and fabulous
a little surprised George Lucas because
he was a Star Wars guy yeah
now speaking of pixels
um you have a recent book called the
biography of the pixel which I
understand you spent 10 years writing
two years wow and if I understand right
the pixel is sort of broadly construed
as the connection between the analog and
the digital world is that right I think
that's a fair way to put it tell us a
bit more about it and so one of the one
of the motivations for this book
is that
that we all now
I think it's
a one with 21 zeros out here in my
capture the number of pixels
nobody's knows what they are
this is their culture now and nobody
knows what these are that's just wrong
at some of them and so I decided to
write this book where I would with no
math okay explain just intuitively what
what they are okay and that's the first
two chapters of my book beautiful and uh
so here's the way I like to explain it
you think of a picture
as a Rumple sheet a little cloth where
the heights of the rumples or the
brightnesses of the of the image and you
let this Clause settle down over a bed
of sharp nails
evenly spaced right
and
you only Preserve
the points on that cloth that touch the
sharp nails
you throw away the Infinity of other
other
in other words you sample right the
Continuum that's the image
sure way to continue it and only
preserve the discrete samples
sampling the magic of the sampling
theorem is that if you do that right
you have you've saved everything
the samples are a perfect representation
it sounds like you're getting away with
murder yeah you're throwing away at
Infinity but not losing it that's what
it says if you do it right yeah so
unless a beautiful way to describe it
because it's very visual but but but
here's the problem
their points their point samples you
can't see a point zero Dimensions right
they never were little squares ever
that's like a point misconception yeah
it's one of the biggest misconceptions
of our modern world they never were
little squares pixelation is a false
idea
um
you can't see a pixel it's because yeah
points
my cell phone's full of probably
billions of pixels you can't see them
they're yeah files in there right
so what happens well you click on a file
name or whatever and suddenly there's a
picture on the screen of your your cell
phone or your computer what's happened
right there well each of those samples
has been
spread by
a little blob of light it's continuous
an analog blob of light there's an
evenly space to cross your display those
are not pixels those are what I call
display elements right
but they're not digital they're not
little squares they're analog they're
driven yeah
and the sampling theorem says if you do
that spreading of the pixels properly
then the then the Continuum of the
little slop boy spots add up to perform
to form the Continuum that was
originally there
yeah it is the magic that we all live in
every day take it for granted right now
this video is being done that way
absolutely yeah
you can't escape it it's in fact the way
I say it is I call it the whole class of
pictures made of pixels I call it
Digital Light
it's uh fast
in fact
nearly every picture in existence
today is part of Digital Light
you can go to kindergartens or
these art museums to see the old analog
stuff yeah but that's just tiny tiny
part and if you think about the digital
explosion
that nearly every picture that has ever
existed
is now
part of additional life absolutely it's
a huge thing yeah so that's the
motivation for the book is like come on
people we need to sell it right there
yeah and it sort of just happened at the
millennium
of course in Italy that'll you know and
I use Toy Story of the first movie as a
as an example of the moment when all old
media types analog media types converged
into one the digital medium it all
happened just about two thousand plus or
minus yeah and I call it the great
digital convergence it went right by
nobody seemed to notice and I'd say wait
wait a minute yeah this is huge this is
what we do every day yeah and uh and
then we just take it for granted no you
know people know you I mean
kids don't even know it was ever
different than that
right so I talk I spent a lot of time
talking about Moore's Law you know how
we we're puny human beings we can't
think
exponentially yeah into the future but
also you can't think exponentially
backwards unless you were there yeah so
you know kids they they have no idea
what it was like 100 billion a factor of
100 billion ago yeah which it was in
1965 when I made my first computer
graphic image yeah they shouldn't have
to when they started now it's an
interesting fact but yeah that's what it
is yeah so yeah
we're sitting at a Moore's Law factor of
100 billion over 100 billion right now
it's going to hit a trillion in about
three years I think
everything good about computers we had a
trillion times better
than it was in 1965. I mean every
possible way that you can think of yeah
yeah if you were born into that you
start there lucky you yeah my
I'm sorry you know I'm in my 80th year
now that means I'm gonna get to see
where it goes but having seen it before
and after we we share a sense of wonder
about it then yeah that's what I'm
trying to pass on in the book is yeah
this is a wondrous thing here's how to
appreciate that in fact that's one way I
think about my book is
because the Digital Light appreciation
course yeah it's like music appreciation
if you the more you you you can't be
back yourself but you can appreciate it
by Annoying a little bit yeah but back
then or what students
right same goes and those of us who have
lived without it kind of get the get the
difference a little bit more than if
they've been born with it so
so let's talk about your life as an
artist a little bit for us and
theoretical computer science
um you're the creator of an iconic image
for us synapse which is the cover of the
fox proceedings which has been used for
41 years
um what's the story behind that piece
so I I had when I made it I have made
one computer graphic image but just one
okay and it was a spiral between the
spiral used for a weather satellite that
was it uh I really wasn't into it yet
yeah
um so
when I interviewed for a job out of
Stanford I interviewed in two places
three actually
but one of them was IBM Watson Research
Center beautiful yeah no the one in New
York Times yeah yeah Yorktown nice and
the other was New York City well I was
young I'm very mad I had
question about it so but I went up I
loved Yorktown high so much I grew up
hanging
with the cotton mountains with
them uh Arnie Rosenberg was one of those
guys and
I had so I had the cover in 1971 for
scientific America people kind of knew
that yeah
so Arnie asked me to design a cover for
FedEx I think we were still calling it
switching an automatic theory okay yeah
the swap is now known as box all right
foundations of computer science uh the
14th was still Swatch I'm pretty sure
um
foreign
because I like designing covers and
posters and things like that
and it finally happened
one day when I was
it was uh winter
in the Bronx
in a blizzard
and my car broke down I was commuted
from somewhere my car broke down and I
was forced into this so station in the
Bronx it was you red white and blue but
it's dirty yeah white blue because yeah
black from traffic
ugly version of an so station not one of
those pretty artistic version okay uh
and my you know my car was broken
somehow so I was gonna have to spend
hours it was a horribly ugly place in
the middle of a blizzard
how do I yeah
survive this yeah I said now if we
design the cover you can do it in your
head right now do it now
so without without
um
thinking about it you know I just saw
something else okay well yeah yeah you
know I was
my hands and the synapses came up I was
always into how the brain was structured
I knew yeah about that and I
you know I love the idea that somehow
we're going to figure out how
structured things yeah did this but you
know
yeah
amazing so I have the
basic concept and when when I finally
did make it back home I spent the next
month executing it oh wow but it was
born in an association
so and I did it with India Inc Telegraph
and Vellum and French curve I mean no
computers
through my hands
by looking at them and uh
well we're very excited that we have the
original here
yeah absolutely amazing so
um and so many of us have sort of grown
up with it through our careers so it's
it's willing again I'm really proud
that's probably my great
yeah my greatest contribution the
foundation is a computer science
many full but that's one of them so
um now in a career as rich and diverse
is yours
is there a Common Thread that you see
going through all of the Just the
multitude of activities and a through
line that you can through on
well it's it's got to be the next year
technology you know a lot of technology
and love of of art
um
in fact one of the
I think one of the perhaps The Secret of
Pixar's success
just uh and maybe it's because of my
backgrounds
we never let this pernicious distinction
between
the technically creative and the
artistically creative to exist we would
not allow and I've been almost every
other place does allow it so I've been
at Microsoft where if you're smart you
program otherwise you do the simple
stuff of artistic and marketing and all
that good stuff no no no no no no no
that's so wrong and if you're in a
graphic arts house
to the creatives
are the cool people in the Techno it's
the tech noise yes
oh people no it was so wrong we would
never let that happen
because they both required each other's
creativity you know it's different
there's no question about it and they
both exist in the same people too as
you're like yeah yes they can and but
yeah they've gotta and it it's not just
words you had you know they had equal
promotion capabilities and
um salaries you know everything was the
same but most important a mutual
admiration Society for
appreciate what they
did so wrong yeah right yeah that's a
great philosophy so
um so last but what does theoretical
computer science have in common with the
movies is there a connection there
because we've gone from one all the way
to the other well
I you know I I really don't know how to
answer that well but yeah you know I
even though I
just AI back in the past and changed
careers to do something that would
happen in my lifetime like make the
first movie yeah I did it now we're now
we're back wait a minute where are we
now exactly and it's turned out to be
kind of more surprising and different
than I thought it would be which of
course of course the horse law says yeah
I don't know what you can't no you can't
even imagine
so the first sign that and I is not
entering you but this is kind of
I'm thinking about
this I ran into a
a former colleague another pixel Packer
like myself
in Cambridge
English my wife
I was on we were on her sabbatical at
King's College it's a tourist College
yeah pretty amazing and um
this friend of mine approached me say
hey Alvin we don't we don't have to
program anymore
and I said well what do you mean he said
look at this
and he handed me a paper which turns out
to be from Berkeley okay
I call it the the horse and zebra paper
uh where you train a a network again
with a thousand pictures of horses just
arbitrary thousand pictures of zeros
Pirates no no text at all just pictures
and when it's trained certainly you can
hang
the network a picture an arbitrary
picture of horses and it will help with
that same picture to you where every
horse has been replaced by a zebra
or vice versa yeah okay so I looked at
that I went
house I don't think that's a well post
problem I mean it was a horse what's a
zebra yeah he said that's the point we
don't know and it's too hard to reverse
engineer it yeah and all of a sudden I
went oh my God and here's what I'm going
to try to interview a little bit went oh
my God I always thought I'd be able to
understand
when we got to
the sophisticated level how it all
worked and of course that's what
attorney told us wasn't the case yeah we
can't even tell you whether algorithm is
going to hold for Christ's sake
by the way the halting problem was done
by Martin Davis not turkey okay he named
it and he proved it
that's interesting yeah you don't know
if my chapter three is the reason all
right now he's really
you know it was such a trivial turn on
the printing problem that during did
Proof yeah that I'd be embarrassed to
everybody
say that but it's true okay he named it
the holding problem okay
yes but we think yeah a little old man
up on the hill right here
uh who saved me in chapter three where I
got a little over there
it's 80s writing about computation
Theory all right so chapter three is
about computation theories about two or
eight
fabulous yeah I bring up girls I mean I
don't explain what I wanted to do was
prove
uh touring had invented the store
program computer
a lot of people think with some
Engineers
right here and I explained his proof and
show you where the program gets put into
the memory and the data gets but yeah he
had the idea
now so the hardware versions are just to
make the idea go fast that's all yeah of
course yeah that's the secret
competition it's got to go fast
um
so I shouldn't be surprised
because
of undesirability we
shouldn't be surprised you get off in
the weird spaces of competition things
are going to happen that we cannot
explain
so you know I think of what
my friends like dick hard it was they
piled into computation you know simple
touring copy station Theory and started
figuring out what was the complexity of
competition yes really important and
trying to find their way through all
these strange back ways trying to
understand it or at least prove that you
can't understand it so right yeah right
and we need more that yeah I think we
need so I wish I surely we could get
further in than we are yeah
understanding what's happening out there
maybe I'm wrong with my intuition is
that what we're doing now is we're
computing
we're Computing we're letting the
program's compute on themselves which we
disallowed most of my Computing career
we've never let a program right on
itself
right the operating system won't allow
that right separate but a naturalness
that's exactly what's going on yeah you
get in there
yeah
yeah and maybe this will finally come
out of it I'm convinced I mean that's my
belief system is if you understand how
this works but it's just a belief system
all right well you made a few movies in
the meantime and it gave us tremendous
you know new technology and lots of Art
in the in the front
if I say one more thing about art itself
I think I think we're exploding right
now first of all that's final God
computation of compute sophisticated
computer Graphics computation is now
real time right the Unreal Engine is
doing what we only dreamed of
a few decades ago in real time yeah
completely gaming and just what yeah
yeah and right yeah
Ordinary People
either have access to it or soon will
and the artists are already starting to
explode
it's holding them because yeah I think
this is going to be
I can I can put it a little bit more
Focus
um and this is in my book one of the
things that we at computer graphics
adopt it without even thinking about it
is what I call the central dogma of
computer Graphics we will model
using three-dimensional euclidean
geometry in our computer memories and we
will also use new Tooling in physics for
the gravity and for the motion in the
Optics okay and we will project that
into two Dimensions using Renaissance
perspective okay
every movie Pixar's made honors the
central dogma in fact any of the movies
that have been made using
to come from what is
the symphonic come on from within the
symbolic formula I'm calling the central
dogma so what I want to say to the
artists who are about to have all this
in their own ends is break out of the
central dogma all right there's no
reason there's nothing about computers
that forces us into the central dogma
show us what else is out there
in Frontier so we'll have to check in in
five years and see what they did
yeah yeah
well thank you so much for coming and
talking with us today
um it's been wonderful to hear about
your many experiences and to meet the
man who also created that image that's
so iconic for all of us
you're welcome thank you it's been fun